Queens in lawns is the single most
popular complaint we get from most
homeowners and what what we need to get
people to understand is that the weeds
are invading because they're more
competitive and they're more competitive
because we are not creating a growing
environment that makes the grass more
competitive so if you've just got a few
weeds here and there hand weeding is
always an option this is where mowing
ties in with weeds because when you mow
too low the plants are less competitive
and when the plant when the grass plants
are less competitive the weeds are more
competitive if you can tolerate some
small patches of weeds in your lawn
you shouldn't have to really do much
about weed control but if you let the
weeds get too prolific then you'll have
more weeds than grass most people find
that objectionable so you want to find
that balance and a lot of that is mowing
properly feeding properly irrigating
selectively to keep the grass
competitive making sure you've got the
right grass for what it is you're
willing to do for it you have to set
your expectations and then recognize
your you know what you're willing to do
to get that long